presentation this webinar will be
focused on understanding space health
through omics i will talk about what
omics is
what is this
theme or this branch of science all
about what are the various opportunities
where early career scientists as i would
like to say
would get an opportunity to do some
hands-on
how we are providing an opportunity to
start your own project in the domain of
space omics
and a lot is there to talk about so
without any further ado
let's move on to today's webinar
so
i'm pretty much sure that
all of you present here today has been
inspired by this
extraordinary field of science which is
space science
be it the first
person in space yuri gagarin
or the milestone event
that is the landing of human on the moon
by neil armstrong and edwin aldrin
or maybe the recent
commercial launches like bob and doug on
spacex or the other space tourism-based
flights
these are all our inspiration and that
was the exact name of the recent
commercial flight as well where people
those who are not
astronauts went to space so this is an
exciting time to be enthusiastic about
space science in general
and according to statistics
around 20 percent of the kids
worldwide have a dream of becoming an
astronaut
so i'm pretty sure that many people who
are present today in the audience once
in their lifetime have definitely dreamt
about becoming an astronaut i would
admit i have done the same but as we
grew up we took different branches of
science went on to study different
specialization and somehow that dream of
ours kind of faded away
me being a biologist
never thought that i can be a part of
space science or the space industry in
any form but here we are the new domain
of space science astrobiology has made
my dream possible and today we are going
to talk about how
you can also begin your journey as an
astrobiologist or a specs space omix
specialist
whenever you look up into the night sky
see these brilliant stars the brilliant
planets
i'm pretty much sure you must have
wondered if we are alone in this
universe are we the only place where
life can exist
or there might be some place far away in
the distance maybe millions of light
years away
there's someone waving at us
we don't know with the scientific
advancements that we have had over the
past years
we have only found one planet that has
life on it and that's our very own
planet earth
the blue marvel as it is seen from space
above the only planet in the entire
universe to our knowledge so far where
life can sustain and thrive harmoniously
but
in the recent times
there has been debates and talks and
speculations about other planets being
host to various
life forms or maybe
they've had life forms
many years ago mars our neighboring red
planet is one of them for sure and
recently in the year 2020 nasa launched
the milestone rover which was named
perseverance to mars and its sole
mission was to
study astrobiological
symptoms or signals which we also call
as biosignatures or techno signatures on
the surface of mars
the perseverance rover which you can see
here is called an astrobiology robot so
with the name you can understand its
mission is to look for potential life
forms
or
to
find out the relics of ancient life
forms
one of the major goals of perseverance
rover is to drill in the martian soil
collect the soil sample and make it
ready for a return mission so you must
be wondering what are the scientists up
to
when they get the soil samples right the
soil samples back on earth now what so
that's where
our topic kicks in that is space omics
these soil samples are being brought
back to earth to analyze them through
a technique which is known as
metagenomics what is metagenomics all
about we will be talking in depth during
our one month program but in short
metagenomics is a technique of
analyzing the
dna rna or any of those nucleic acid
remains in the soil samples in the raw
soil samples that's pretty exciting i'm
pretty excited excited for it as well so
looking forward to talking more about it
but apart from mars
there are other places as well where we
expect life to exist
one of them is jupiter's moon europa
europa is a frosty satellite it's
covered with thick layers of ice but
it has been
speculated
under scientific grounds
that underneath the thick layer of ice
there remains liquid water just like
when the lakes freeze when you have
snowfall but under those frozen layers
of ice
the fishes can live
pretty much comfortably because the
water underneath is still warm and in
liquid form
and if that's the case if liquid is
liquid water is present on europa
doesn't that make you wonder
whether europa has some sort of aquatic
life if not macro sized life maybe
microbes and that's the reason why nasa
has planned to send this particular
rover robot mission which is known as a
europa clipper
in the 2030s and this is really an
exciting time to be enthusiastic about
astrobiology and space science in
general because you can witness all of
these things happening and who knows
maybe one of you guys sitting
right in the audience today could be
that person who discovers
extraterrestrial life for the first time
i'm pretty much hopeful for it
so talking about various projects
enthusiasm
being excited about astrobiology just
like sunalika introduced in the
introductory part the lara diken is
an omixlogic research fellow she has
been
working on several astrobiological
projects with us and one of our projects
was the analyzing the radiation threat
on the gut microbiome of astronauts
so
now i would like to
transfer the stage to her so that she
can share
her experience her journey of becoming
an astrobiological scientist
how did she get excited and what
motivated her to take that extra step
from being an enthusiast
to transition into someone who is
actively working in this domain
so what was her motivation
and what are the benefits that she
experiences being an active astrobiology
scientist let's hear it from her so